you have something with inganu that
there's if he has any card to play with
dana it's the fact that dana i think
anyway
has been waiting patiently for the mega
fight of the decade he's been waiting
two years for jon jones to get his
weight up and he wants to ngano john
jones fight so i don't think he's going
to let him know donald john jar they
even in the same weight class oh no they
are they are john
john jones has gotten to be a
heavyweight and he's big and he's you
know he's got that that light light
heavyweight mentality meaning the fact
that he can fight in many different ways
he can wrestle he can do who would be
favored in that fight
i mean
you're talking about arguably the number
one ufc fighter in history
is ring rust a real thing is ring rust a
real thing
yeah ring rust is a real thing it is a
real thing and um but it also depends on
like who you are as a fighter you know
what i'm saying sometimes people go out
there and they exhibit that kind of ring
rust but i mean when you're out for so
long
uh the game changes like that in subtle
ways that um if you're not in there you
don't you don't you don't even realize
because there's so much that goes into
being able to fight you know it's a it's
more mental than it is physical when it
gets down to you know fight week and
being in the cage on fight day so you
have to be able to uh you know bring
yourself there a little bit every single
day and stay on top of the mental game
if you don't stay on top of the mental
game then when you get out there you can
go out there and experience some ring
rust so you think somebody like jon
jones even one of maybe the single best
fighter of all time
two years out of the ring he's going to
get that adrenaline dump the ring rust
and then you have somebody like ingano
in there
it's recipe for disaster do you think
jon jones is just so good jon jones is
so good but here there's something
different about jon jones like jon jones
one thing that i really like about jon
jones and i hold high praises for him
four is because of the fact that you
know his life could be falling apart
around
uh a fight but yet when he's in the cage
he's laser and focus and he's locked in
that right there is a talent that a lot
of people can't can't do you know for me
i had a hard time juggling life outside
and then getting inside the cage and not
letting it affect my performance so
being able to do that is an art form in
itself and jon jones has been able to
you know he's exhibited that time and
time again so it's hard to say if jon
jones is going to go and fall for it and
you know go and have the ring rust that
you would anticipate anybody else being
out as long as he
do you think we'll win if these guys
face each other
man
it's a tough one to call to be honest
and i'm not just trying to say that to
try to give a 50 50 answer but
you know you have francis who is you
know has been a sponge you know
training with francis and seeing
france's growth from the time he started
to where he is now it's hard to say that
he can't do all those things that a
mixed martial artist fighters can do you
know before it was like only he only had
the big power well now he can grapple
now he can wrestle now he can defend
takedowns now he has a better
understanding of where the fight needs
to be and how to get a guy to in his
fight you know and then you have jon
jones at the aspect you know who
understands a great flow of a fight has
great defense and at the same time he's
just very smart inside the cage so it's
a very tough one to call but i mean
here's here's the thing that i think
about when i think about this matchup is
that you know when jon jones was at you
know
205 his last few fights he was getting
caught with some punches you know and it
was making him look a little bit more
human so i would say if he goes up the
heavyweight and he doesn't patch up
those holes then he can get caught with
a big shot and and
peak peak of jon jones
versus francis is it even if i'm talking
peak peak when john was peaking where
you you were in the ring with these
people yeah yeah
jon jones is something special when
you're speaking i mean
to to fight to fight how jon jones used
to fight and back then it was just it
was ridiculous because he was so um he
was so creative inside the octagon and
he had no fear
so when you don't have any fear and you
have that creativity you're looking at
somebody who was just absolutely dynamic
and then his athleticism and his range
and everything else that he had so i
would say jon jones you know um you know
people's you know they don't want to
give jon jones credit because of the
things that he's done and things like
that but you know when you look at the
talent just of what he's been able to do
i mean you just you got to give it to
him because
he's he's working with a different set
of skills when it comes to effectiveness
i was using
yeah where they stopped him was like oh
my gosh i didn't know you can't do this
it was just like natural to him
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]